Okay,
um,
before we get started with this video,
I had one little announcement to make,
but I forgot what it was.
Um.
Oh yeah.
As you can see,
we have reached 10,000
subscribers on the length focus channel.
Thank you for helping me reach 10,000.
Let's keep it going.
Let's hit fifty thousand one hundred
thousand.
Let's see how big this gets,
but you guys are the original crew.
Thank you for your support from day one.
So let's get into today's topic.
I'm going to talk about the Persian
language.
It's sometimes known as Farsi,
but I'm going to call it Persian.
Persian is a language that is widely
spoken in parts of the Middle East and
in Central Asia,
and it has a long history stretching
back thousands of years with a few
different stages along the way.
The Persian language originated in
southwestern Persia.
Wait,
I don't see Persia on this map right
here.
Oh,
that's right.
Today.
Persia is known as Iran.
Persian is the one official language of
Iran and it is the native language of
about half of Iranians.
The statistics actually range from about
45 to 55 percent,
but I'm going to say half and that makes
it 38 point 5 million people,
but virtually all other Iranians can
speak Persian as a second language as
well.
Persian is also an official language in
two other countries,
but you might not know that because they
refer to the language by different names
in those places.
In Afghanistan,
the language is referred to as dory for
political reasons,
but speakers of Dari,
Persian themselves often called their
language Farsi.
It's actually really hard to get
reliable statistics about Afghanistan,
but most sources seem to say that it is
spoken by 25 to 30 percent of the
population in Afghanistan,
but it is also widely used as a Lingua
Franca and pretty much everyone in the
country can speak.
Dari in Tajikistan.
Persian is referred to as [inaudible]
because that's what the Soviet Union
conquers decided to call it.
You know how foreign empires like to
divide and conquer?
No,
no.
Don't be friends with that powerful
country over there.
No,
no,
no.
You're.
You're separate.
You're distinct from them,
but touching Persian is indeed a variety
of Persian.
It is spoken by 6 million people in
Tajikistan and another one point 5
million people in the nearby Central
Asian countries,
especially in Uzbekistan.
Person has also spoken by about $5
million expatriates around the world,
especially in some Middle East countries
like Iraq,
UAE,
Bahrain,
uh,
places like that,
as well as the USA.
So let's recap in your round.
There are about 38 point 5 million
native speakers of Persian in
Afghanistan and Pakistan.
There are $11 million native speakers of
Dari,
Persian in Tajikistan and surrounding
areas.
There are seven point 5 million native
speakers of touchy Persian and there are
about $5 million pat speaking Persian
around the world that comes to a total
of $62 million native speakers.
But if we include all the second
language speakers of Persian who use it
as a Lingua Franca,
then the number rises to 110 million
speakers around the world are Persian,
dirty and tragic.
All really the same language.
Yes,
they are varieties of one single
language.
They are mutually intelligible,
especially among educated speakers and
the formal languages are very close to
each other.
There are some differences in the casual
language,
especially in the accent and some of the
vocabulary that's used,
some of the spelling,
things like that,
but basically they are one language and
they are mutually intelligible.
One difference that I often come across
as the lone words in the different
varieties,
so in Iran there are more French loan
words.
In Afghanistan there are more English
loan words end in Tajikistan.
There are more Russian loan words.
Some people who are not so familiar with
the Persian language might assume that
it's related to the Arabic language
because Iran is in the middle,
east end is next to Iraq,
but actually Persian is in a totally
different language family.
Then the Arabic language,
it is in the Indo European language
family.
That means that person shares historical
origins with most of the languages in
Europe,
including English,
as well as the languages of northern
India,
and most speakers have Indo European
languages find Persian much easier to
learn the Arabic because of the
grammatical similarity,
but it does look like Arabic because for
historical reasons,
Persian is usually written in the Arabic
script except in Tajikistan.
Let's look at the history.
First,
there was old Persian,
the oldest known records of old Persian
or in inscriptions dating back to the
first Persian empire.
These writings are written in Babylonian
cuneiform script,
which is one of the oldest writing forms
in the world.
We have writings like this from various
places that were part of the first
Persian empire,
including Iran of course,
but also Romania,
Armenia,
Iraq,
Bahrain,
Turkey,
and Egypt.
Next,
there was middleperson from about 300
bce until about 800 ce old Persian
developed into middle Persian,
which is also known as [inaudible].
We can find middleperson mainly in
religious texts of the Zoroastrian
religion from before the Islamic period.
The language was referred to as parsing
or poor sick during this time period
because it was the language of the
parcel of people.
The person language entered a mysterious
new stage with the Islamic conquest in
6:50,
one add the following 200 years are
referred to by Iranian scholars as two
centuries of silence because there is
very little almost no literature
available from that time period.
We don't know exactly why,
but it's possible that it was forbidden
to write in the Persian language by the
Arab rulers.
These two centuries of silence or a kind
of transition period from middle Persian
to modern Persian and person was
affected by it.
The Arabic language quite a lot during
this time that brings us to modern
Persian or new Persian.
Around 800 ce.
The person language was in danger of
being lost and replaced by Arabic,
but Persia was one of the few places
where the Arabic language did not
replace the local language.
However,
Arabic was used by the intellectuals and
by the elite and it definitely had a big
impact on the vocabulary of the modern
Persian that was emerging.
After the end of Arab rule in Persia in
the ninth century,
the Persian language and culture was
once again reinvigorated and a new
period of classic literature and poetry
rose.
One important piece of literature was
Ferdowsi.
He's showed me the book of Kings,
which is the longest work of epic poetry
ever written.
It was so influential on future
literature and cultural identity that
the Persian language today remains
relatively unchanged from that time.
This one epic poem is a sort of pillar
of the Persian language.
It is said that Ferdowsi intentionally
limited the number of Arabic loan words
used in his epic poem in order to help
preserve the integrity of the Persian
language.
Of course,
there's still are a significant number
of Arabic words in Persian,
but not as many as there could have been
during this Persian cultural resurgence.
The Persian language and culture
impacted a wide geographic area.
Persian became the official language of
the Seljuk Empire extending into present
day Turkey and later was the first
official language of the Ottoman Empire.
Turkish later became the official
language of the Ottoman Empire,
but it's vocabulary had been very
influenced by Arabic and Persian,
Persian also spread to the Indian
subcontinent where it was widely spoken
until the arrival of the British person
has left its influence on a lot of
different languages,
including a heavy influence on the
vocabulary of Urdu and also some
influence on the vocabulary of Turkish,
but you can find words of Persian origin
in languages as far away as the Malay
language in Malaysia and of course there
are English words that are of Persian
origin.
Some of them came directly into English
from Persian,
but most of them came in directly into
English via different language.
Bizarre Bronze Jekyll Kiosk,
lemon mogul,
mummy,
Pajama,
scarlet serendipity Shawl,
tulip,
turban,
Typhoon Khaki,
Caravan Paradise.
The Word Checkmate actually comes from
Sha,
which means the king is dead and maybe
tiger though that one is disputed.
Learning Persian is a great idea because
you will be able to speak with 110
million Persian speakers around the
world,
but it also gives you access to a rich
history of literature and insight into a
culture that has had a big impact on the
world and if you ever decide to learn
Arabic in the future after learning
Persian,
then you will already know a lot of
Arabic words from Persian.
Thank you for watching the length focus
channel.
I hope that was educational.
If you have any comments,
write them down below and have a nice.